[Musique]
dans la campagne du donbass nous avons
rendez vous avec l'élite des artilleurs
ukrainien
concentration extrême et commandant aux
aguets cette unité utilisent les fameux
canons caesar livrés par la france
allait très vite soyez prêts lieu de
rendez vous communiquez au tout dernier
moment
cet officier se retourne et s'inquiètent
car un duel d'artillerie et déjà en
cours
voici les césars
trois canons français au coeur de la
bataille du don brasse
alignement dans ce champ de colza
préparation au tir
procédure millimétré et obus de 155 mm
la cible aujourd'hui
des pièces d'artillerie russe
positionné à 17 kilomètres
ce sont très souvent écoutez bien
c'est l'arrivée des obus sur les
objectifs visés
seulement quatre minutes et 20 secondes
dans ce champ puis c'est déjà le départ
juste après avoir tiré les artilleurs
doivent partir au plus vite pour éviter
d'être repéré par l'ennemi ce que nous
faisons bien sûr nous aussi
nous repartons vers une base militaire
que nous ne filme on pas cette brigade
c'est la cible à abattre
aux yeux des russes
dans cette pièce un officier fait les
comptes
image dallas puis après chaque tir de
césar des drones de surveillance
ukrainien survole les cibles visées ici
des chars russes détruits il y a
quelques jours et décors de nombreux
soldats ennemis
c'était impressionnant pour les demies
ce jour là
et les soldats qui étaient encore
vivants dans cette colonne que nous
avons visé d'essayer de se disperser et
de se cacher sous les arbres
ce commandant à 6 et 1 re à sa
disposition selon lui ils ont permis
l'élimination d'au moins 80 pièces
d'artillerie russe
il accepte de nous emmener sur un court
entraînement à l'arrière du front
ces jeunes artilleurs ukrainiens ont été
formés en france en pleine guerre il y à
un mois sur une base militaire dans le
sud de l'hexagone
ont été envoyés en france pour étudier
la technique de tir du césar
on a reçu beaucoup d'informations
on a dû tout comprendre le plus vite
possible en moins de deux semaines
maîtrisé par exemple le système
d'entraidé coordonnées de la cible à lux
le césar c'est la fierté de l'artillerie
française
il tire six obus à la minute à une
distance de 40 km avec une grande
précision il est surtout montés sur
camions une mobilité qui sauvent des
vies
nos ennemis utilisent des moyens
modernes de renseignement et des drones
pour nous repérer
il ne faut donc pas resté longtemps sur
le chantier
il ne faut pas leur laisser le temps de
répliquer
le césar et très manoeuvrable il permet
de partir vite
face à la puissance de feu des russes
les ukrainiens dispose donc désormais
entre autres de 18 césar